das schlafzimmer
der weckruf
der wecker
stehen
ich stehe um sieben uhr morgens auf
ich bin um sieben uhr morgens
aufgestanden
es ist sonntag
das ist mein freier tag
es ist mein freier tag
der sonntag ist der tag an dem ich mich
um das haus und um mich selbst kümmere
aber zuerst werde ich ein wenig
trainieren
laufen
ich laufe in den park ich laufe in den
park
ich bin in den park gelaufen
ich bin in den park gelaufen der park
ich trainiere im fitnessstudio ich
trainiere im fitnessstudio
ich habe im fitnessstudio trainiert
das fitnessstudio
training
ein
nach dem training frühstücke ich nach
dem training frühstücke ich zum
frühstück trinke ich immer einen kaffee
zum frühstück trinke ich immer einen
kaffee
ich habe einen kaffee getrunken ich habe
einen kaffee getrunken
und ich esse einen joghurt mit müsli und
ich esse einen joghurt mit müsli ich
habe einen joghurt mit müsli gegessen
ich habe einen joghurt mit müsli
gegessen
ich habe geflüchtet
das frühstück
frühstücken nach dem frühstück wasche
ich mich
nach dem frühstück wasche ich mich
sich waschen ich bade ich bade ich habe
gebadet
ich habe gebadet die badewanne baden
oder ich dusche mich
ich habe mich geduscht
dusche
sich duschen
ich traue mir die haare ich trockne mir
die haare
ich habe meine haare getrocknet
trockene haare der föhn
ich kenne meine haare
ich habe meine haare gekämmt
die haare kämmen
der kam
ich putze mir die zähne
ich habe mir die zähne geputzt
sich die zähne putzen
die
an pasta
die zahnbürste
ich trage die creme auf
ich habe die creme aufgetragen
die creme auftragen
die gesichtscreme
das badezimmer
jetzt bin ich bereit das haus
aufzuräumen jetzt bin ich bereit das
haus aufzuräumen
ich räume das zimmer auf
ich habe das zimmer aufgeräumt
aufräumen
ich glaube dass bücher
ich glaube das bücherregal ab
ich habe das bücherregal abgestaubt
abstoss
der staubwedel
der staub
das arbeitszimmer
ich staubsauger
ich habe staub gesaugt
staubsaugen
der staubsauger
ich wische den boden
ich habe den boden
ist
den bot
inwischen
der wischmopp
das wohnzimmer
ich wasche die wäsche
ich habe die wäsche
ich habe die wäsche gewaschen
wäsche waschen
die waschmaschine
ja
das waschmittel
der weichspüler
die wasch
höher
ich hänge die wäsche auf
aber die wäsche aufgehängt
die wäsche aufgehängt
wäsche zum trocknen aufhängen
ich fühle die kleidung
ich bettle die kleidung
ich habe die kleidung gebügelt ich habe
die kleidung gebügelt
das bügelbrett
das bügeleisen
sind
ich koche das mittagessen
ich habe das mittagessen gekocht
kochen
ich esse zu mittag
ich habe zu mittag gegessen
essen
ich wasche das geschirr ab
habe das geschirr abgewaschen
ich habe das geschirr abgewaschen
das geschirr abwaschen
[Musik]
das geschirr abtrocknen
leider habe ich keine spülmaschine
die küche
was hast du an deinem freien tag gemacht
hast du an deinem freien tag gemacht
schreibe es in die kommentare
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video